[موسيقى]
نعم ماليزيا دوله ديمقراطيه فقط من حيث ان
شعبها قادر على تغيير الحكومات بواسطه
الحكومات لكن الديمقراطيه تتطلب ايضا حريه
التعبير وحريه الصحافه وايضا صياده
القانون كل هذه الامور تاتي جميعا مع
الديمقراطيه غير اننا ورغم اننا ننتخب
حكومتنا فاننا من ناحيه حريه التعبير ما
زلنا في الخلف لاننا دوله متعدده الاعراق
ومن المهم ان لا تتقاتل هذه الاعراق
[موسيقى]
نعم لكن الديمقراطيه تترجم باشكال مختلفه
عبر مختلف الدول في ماليزيا وبسبب ان
لدينا دوله متعدده الاعراق فان الاوكد
والاهم ان لا تكون لنا خلافات او اشتباكات
او صراع بين مختلف مكونات المجتمع ولذلك
فان كل ما من شانه ان يدفع الاعراق على
التقاطع غير مسموح به ولذلك فانه في الوقت
الذي لديك كامل الحريه فانه ينبغي ان تكون
لك الحريه في تحديد سرعه تلك الحقيقه كلما
استدعى الامر ولذلك فان ماليزيا هي
ديمقراطيه غير ليبراليه
[موسيقى]
هناك عده اشكال للديمقراطيه لا يوجد شكل
محدد معياري هناك ثقافات وعادات وظروف
ينبغي اخذها بعين الاعتبار مثلا في
بريطانيا هناك ملك ولكنه لا يتمتع
بالسلطات تنفيذيه لقد اتبعنا هذا النظام
في امريكا حتى رئيس السلطه الحكوميه يجري
انتخابه من قبل الشعب لذلك فانهم
ليبراليون اكثر ومع ذلك في امريكا نفسها
هناك الكثير من الميز العنصري خاصه ضد
السود لذلك فانه حتى امريكا لا يصح ان
نطلق عليها صفه ديمقراطيه كامله
[موسيقى]